there's a lot happening president joe
biden came to office
promising changes in u.s policy toward
cuba
but months after he moved into the white
house sanctions remain in place
and diplomacy is strained at best the
crippling effects of the u.s embargo
recently led to the suspension of cash
deposits in u.s dollars
a major source of income for ordinary
cubans
it affects me from the point of view
that i have relatives abroad who send me
foreign currency
but well we will look for other ways for
it to arrive it's all a far cry from
president obama's historic visit
in 2016 when relations were normalized
the u.s
embassy reopened and traveled to cuba
aloud
president biden it seems is not
following suit a cuba policy shift
or additional steps is currently not
among the president's
top foreign policy priorities but it is
an issue of course we
will remain engaged in and focused on in
essence that means retaining
hundreds of tough measures put in place
by president trump
including redesignating cuba a state
sponsor of terrorism
critics of the embargo say despite calls
for democracy and
improved human rights in cuba changes
can be made
they want to see some evidence of
progress um
you know politically economically as but
that's not necessarily
uh an impediment to perhaps taking
initial steps to get rid of some of the
more
strict or tough sanctions that the trump
administration put in place
major modifications to such a complex
and long-standing web of laws would need
congressional approval
something not likely to happen but the
reason behind biden's lack of action
may be more political during the last
presidential election here in florida
democrats suffered losses
in part because president trump was so
tough on cuba
fear of communism runs deep among both
cuban american and hispanic voters
and support for the embargo remains high
the byte administration is keenly aware
of just how crucial those votes are
reason enough perhaps to keep the status
quo
for cuban americans like ingrid arenas
the blame lays
squarely with the cuban government they
don't allow
any young people that of course have new
ideas have a new method have have a good
hopes no they don't allow anybody who
thinks different do something so
it have to be a change the only way for
cuban people
is to change speaking in havana late
last year cuba's foreign minister
condemned the embargo
saying it brought nothing but pain
the us government has tightened in
extreme and unprecedented ways to
blockade against cuba
taking advantage of the terrible
conditions caused by the covenant 19
pandemic
the blockade has always been a criminal
act a genocidal act as established by
the geneva convention an act of economic
warfare
for more than 25 years the u.n general
assembly has voted in favor of ending
the u.s embargo on
cuba but president biden who was part of
the cuban normalization process during
the obama administration
has so far left the embargo firmly in
place
andy gallacher al jazeera miami florida